[music]
ni
yeah yeah
hunting grounds oha
[music]
ah ah ah
your ingenuity
ere
me
[music]
san
[applause]
[music]
tan
ah  Ah ah
[music]
Angers I know this song
Yes I can do it soon It
's okay
ah
ah ah  Karai Romu
Yes
, I used
this.
In reality,
drug development companies have stated that they will not take any criminal responsibility.At the
same time, the companies have
researched the fact that drugs 30 years ago effectively suppressed the God fever virus, and
the patients who became hemostats were viral.  He claimed that it was believed that there
was
a side effect of the drug,
and he announced that the drug itself was not harmful.
In
response to this action, the police, ah, the demonstration marches and
it's already obvious The government has no interest in this string The only thing they are interested in is how to stop the bleeding and
get rid of it
ASAP  [Music]
Yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
Hey I'm running
out of blood and I can't move
Darker guy
Oh yeah yeah
Successful target
neutralization Ingredients for repeated Ruperget neutralization
Hase Yo
Yeah
Always  It's early, it's not the fault of Denma Kuu It seems that the police are setting up nets here and there
Hey, let's stop today It's not good for Yuhei
Gou That's right too
Let's go
I just got here and I can't play around with the money enough to
satisfy you.
is managed by headquarters  It changes every day It's a stilt for me
Please help me
Banana clip
It's a car as the clothes say It's a password I'm
going to send a random beef number to a server that seems to be a
combination Combination  But there
is a chance that
this third r 3 type and the last time the system was upgraded
can't be counted
p Well, don't upgrade here and reset everything
Passwords are reset again  I've got permission to set
it up, and
I wonder if that's possible.  So,
did you release it
ce
ah ah ah ah
Well then,
it's the final preparation
[music] I
wonder if it's a little better
Oh, Himi and the others have
stopped bleeding, isn't it?
If you say that you need this money every time you buy a house, then I have the key
Shut up negative zero licking the end
2006 1 million yen star This is enough
Say it on TV and
this is the end  I got it, I know it's withdrawn
Eh,
shut up I couldn't put that debt together
Blood is taken and sold in the dark It's precious and the aim
is okay, wait a minute skn boo boo chu oh mother I'm done
with the toilet What a
kid  I think it's
duff Didn't you check that it's over?
Don't hurt people just by
taking money
Hahahahahaha
[music]
4 days
dqn Why experiment with this pattern?
Scenery Councilor 16 Block 8
Seniors, hurry to the scene immediately
dgb se
What are you guys doing
?
Woman
Get in the car What are you talking
about Shut up what you're saying
Once the t gps is up I'll be tracked wherever I run
You guys all know that
Bincho
is right I'm fine
Hurry up and run away from here
Hurry up,
no, you should go with me What will it be done
[music]
Yabe yeah
ah ah ah
me
What did you say
[music]
Daily and absolute person type a
police  All
four suspects have been arrested in the Hemostat state, and all of them are minors.
One of them was a half-human who was called a child of peace at the time, and
half-blood
hemostat.
Mouth: My
father is Tenshige.
This training is forging certificates,
obstructing the execution of public duties, violating the Road Traffic Law, and other violations of the
Firearms and Swords Law
.  I don't think you'll be blamed for the matter
th
Ossa, please
stop talking about him
.
I know that's not the case Why did you do that
Awaji-san, you're an interesting person,
aren't you?  will be sentenced to 15 years or less, but it will be enforced under the Minor Protection Law
.
I don't mind if you add one
thing It's okay to say that
the slump did it  I'm going to
put it on your neck, but I'll make you all eat stinky food for the rest of your life
.
- Amagi-kun
I'm asking how to solve it, and
I promise you a satisfactory result.
] Mr.
Handley
Someone drives like this
Anji was with me all the time at the other clinic.Jianfong is a supporter
and is
not included in the plan.  You know, I
can't think of complicated things
See,
you did
it, are you doubting yourself?
I can't see it, but
I'm
sorry.I'm
sorry.I'm sorry.I'm sorry.
[Applause] It's
been
a while since I was a star. What
did
you
come here for
?  I wonder
if you can help me this time
I guess the pst sent me here anyway
.
Leave me alone You wo
n't appear in front of me again I
know we
're not parent and child
anymore
ondemand
me
deshita
ni
hoffi by an dan ana
male
eme
n
ni
[music]
where
ni
tan
ana
as you do me
dare
ani
me
ni
[music]
aname
me
goo
[music]
uh ee
boots
4 days
20 yeah yeah yeah
Par Fine grains that have been judged for crimes they don't remember
are housed in a mysterious facility  What
awaited me there was survival in Chengdu
.